et
je veux jouer
[Musique]
je vais regarder une formation sur la
production de jus d'ananas
après les différentes démonstrations
conte qu'elle vient de me montrer c'est
un téléphone qui s'adapte facilement à
non et c'est un téléphone qui va
beaucoup plus être des mois et un de mes
parents par exemple qui sépare lit
en ce moment
[Musique]
la parole est trois fois plus rapide que
l'écriture donc là je parle plutôt
qu'aux décrit non seulement c'est rapide
donc ça facilite la vie mais d'un autre
côté on a un moteur qui permet
d'interpréter ce que tu as dit pour
terminer une réponse appropriée et
adapté à ce que tu attends donc sa
périlleuse voilà donc nous avons
beaucoup travaillé sur les langues
africaines
et donc ça nous permet à nos parents qui
le peuvent aujourd'hui ne plus être
alphabétisés mais directement utiliser
leur téléphone dans la langue
[Musique]
il